the Joe Rogan experience just a good
old-fashioned show see that [ __ ]
video which one of China where they're
spraying disinfectant in the streets no
they tried to kill the corona virus
Jamie it's on my is that [ __ ] but
they do that some of them are real but
some of them I think are not accurate
videos I don't know I've seen it a
couple different spots a tattoo I've
seen very various ones better watch the
video because it's [ __ ] bonkers man
they're they're driving through the
streets spraying everything at street
light the thing I saw going around
before which is you didn't they were
pairing with drones they're using drone
sex around people see they do a South
with mosquitos yes so it's kind of like
that [ __ ] terrible for YouTube of
what works if you breed that [ __ ] in if
it kills mosquitoes it'll kill you tears
Lily that [ __ ] stuff is off all of
our relatives like go play outside we're
like is this safe they're like yeah just
off do you know let me let's watch this
real quick
Oh fine it's on my Twitter also along
with my man Eddie Izzard is running 28
marathons in 28 days in 28 countries
could all through the month of February
all all in drag I have socks on my floor
look at this look how crazy this is yeah
this is nothing [ __ ] people there
sprang [ __ ] out of cars there was no
street spraying buildings it's all
disinfectant apparently this coronavirus
they say can live outside of a host for
three days so if you have like corona
virus on your hand you touch a railing
that [ __ ] will exist outside of your
body for three days which is very
unusual that's like some parasite [ __ ]
well it's this is what these doctors
have been saying forever the one that
died
that's one yeah but the doctors that
studied at the CDC Duncan and I went to
the CDC down and Galveston I think it is
and we were talking with these
infectious disease experts and we were
all conspiracy theory like we're like
you know like we were worried about like
manmade viruses and this he goes listen
you don't have to worry about manmade
viruses he goes these [ __ ] are
making them they didn't they're mutated
he didn't used to turn [ __ ]
well right well he wanted to
are you saying they they make themselves
and they happen all the time and we
barely can keep up with them and it just
takes one big giant one like the Spanish
flu this crazy thing in Spanish flu is
1920 yes is 2020 so everything every
hundred years yeah I don't want to say
before that was what like yellow fever
or some things probably some [ __ ] in the
1820s yeah like down in the south like
the Carolinas and find out what was the
pandemic in the eto here's the drones
Jesus army of drones deployed across
China dispensed disinfectant see here's
why I call that [ __ ] on that how
much [ __ ] disinfectant can they carry
that little [ __ ] ass bro then I get
a kill you know I mean there's so little
that I ain't gonna kill I can go refill
I love my army of drones there's like
three calm down the thing them driving
through the streets freaked me out more
than anything
yeah that's intense it is intense it's
just like a fall there died the other
thing to that which was scary I think it
was real there was a drone that followed
a woman out of her house she didn't have
a mask on and it was like you ma'am
you're not you don't have a mask please
go home go home you don't have and it
followed her home in China yeah like
that I can't translate so I don't know
if what I was saying was there someone
just made a video to be scary but the
[ __ ] really is like a movie it is it's
it's totally a movie because everyone's
got to be locked down in their houses
and say kids are starving to death
because they're locked in their houses
and their parents are in the hospital
they just had like another I think I got
a notification last night that said
there was like a guy in San Diego that's
being treated and I'm like God yeah it's
it's just a matter of time just let me
do the Rogan podcast before I get
coronavirus you're here and you late
they say he's supposed to wash your
hands a lot but that was before they
realized that it's transmitted through
the air I don't think that happens
what's going on this is the lady this
drone is speaking to you could you
imagine - idea what's going on she's so
hot I didn't walk without wearing a mask
you yes you're better better home don't
forget to wash your hands she's got blue
hair iced yeah I'm [ __ ] around to
make a scary video maybe but I also
could be real now a drone is what it
could be real
well did you come outside I'm asked hmm
the show were melt itself in a few
months what a few months is that a haiku
what is this
stay at home with food and drinks why do
you always come outside you can sort
this out this might be [ __ ] but it
might be real I know I'm not feeling
good about it it scares me man it's like
these things absolutely can wipe out
millions and millions of people before
they can get a handle on it I had it I
was on a plane a couple weeks ago flying
from New Orleans back here and I had
this Viking woman behind me just open
mouth coughing and I had I was like
first of all no yeah second of all I had
to turn around and say hey can you
please cover your mouth and I had to do
that to an adult woman and it made me
feel weird some people were just [ __ ]
self just yeah on that plane some people
just don't care they're just selfish
yeah yeah they don't even care that
other people feel uncomfortable they
just like I have the call yeah and
you're gonna all experience it yeah if
some people if they're sick they want
you to be sick they don't they're not
happy
malicious [ __ ] and malignant
[Applause]